scp-682 versus scp-049  the hard-to-destroy reptile is certainly  a pretty pestilent creature but would  the mild-mannered plague doctor be able  to cure our world of its presence  scp-049 slowly approached the creature  seeming equal parts fascinated and  frightened it murmured the disease  appears to not affect only humans to  itself he closed in to get a better look  and tried to grab 682 but the reptile  immediately growled and swiped at zero  four nine the doctor narrowly dodged  taking any real damage but the  experience shook him he seemed panicked  and a little emotionally disturbed at  his own request he was escorted back to  his containment chamber poor guy